[Music]
a study done
uh about a decade ago
says that
you need to only do three things to
avoid
living in poverty graduate from high
school marry before having a child
and have that child after age 20.
only eight percent of the people who do
those three things
fall into poverty 79 percent who
fail to do those three things in that
order
land in poverty those are statistics not
moral judgments
graduate from high school be married
before you have a baby and be over 20
before you have a baby pretty simple
basic life choices um
and these studies go on from there that
show
you know a 2014 report
american enterprise institute did says
that adjusting for family size family
income is 73 percent
higher for married women
than it is for women who are not married
and living with someone
so as a woman's empowerment
issue there is a tremendous economic
lift statistically speaking
on average when a lady is married
and and so that last call that we take
from that super young girl
she was 20 years old or 21 years old
right
yeah um these decisions that you're
making at that age
especially for women
there's a there's a marriage there's
what's called a marriage lift in
economics too that just shows that
by and large more wealthy people are
married than unmarried
and so there's some dynamic there and it
can just simply be that there's two
incomes
yeah you know the the the math could be
the cause of that we don't know the
causation of it the marriage is
necessarily the causation
but there there just seems to be
something that when people are doing
life together
uh under the heading of marriage that
that there's
you know multiple studies that show that
the probability of you not only avoiding
poverty but being more successful in
your life
yeah i think it's interesting how you
always highlight the economic benefit
to marriage because i think people don't
think of that now let's talk about this
this is interesting though because in
that example with christina in that last
call
i i don't know if she wants to get
married and just isn't or if she didn't
want to get married either but there's
an interesting dynamic where typically
and you know i know you make some people
mad with this but typically
the man proposes and if you're talking
two women
who want to get married who are in a
relationship what would you say to
someone
that wants to get married but her
husband hasn't her boyfriend has not
proposed
because you don't want to be this needy
nag that's like well where's my ring
but at the same time you're like what
are we doing here
what does that look like i mean we're
we're living together and having babies
together so it's kind of like
yeah this is like you know everything
the deal's already done
we just need to sign the deal right and
so this is not like
uh you're dating and you're uh trying to
process there's not a baby on the way
and you've got independent lives
financially and then you're needy that's
not you know
that's a whole different conversation
but um
but i would say a lot of people in
younger generations don't
equate those things that they're and you
get the calls all the time they're
perfectly fine living together and
having babies and not being married
a lot of them do that and so i don't
think in in their mind they equate well
because we're doing this we must get
married or it means we should get
married or we're going to get married
they're just they're just kind of cool
with it you know i think some people
think that so what would you say to
someone
well let's let's continue reading some
of the statistics because i think it
does address that you know i mean
only four percent of homes with a
married mother
and father are on food stamps at any
given time
21 of cohabitating and 28 percent
of single mothers are on food stamps
so these are socio-economic decisions
that you control and uh
and the reason is is that a house
divided against itself can stand
you know when you pull it when you're
pulling it two ends of something all you
do is break it down
yeah you're not pulling in the same
direction you have not you've not
uh committed for the long haul and so
you make short-term decisions
yeah and it blows your money up and it
blows your career up
and it blows your parenting up and it
blows up everything
yeah and so you know
a goal in achieving the american dream
only 41 percent of cohabitating adults
and 44 percent of singles actually
own their own home
where 78 of married people own their own
home
you're twice as likely to be a homeowner
married
see these are all wealth indicators and
so there's something going on here
of the joining of forces uh
versus shacking up yeah and so
you know and and people get all pissed
off because you know your only right to
tell me i don't even write tell you
anything all you got to do is change
your channel if you don't want me
telling you stuff because you're here
you're here because i'm going to tell
you stuff that's that's why we call this
the dave ramsey show
if you want somebody else tell you stuff
get somebody else but
you know there is there is a problem
here that we've just ignored
because everybody's so afraid to address
this because it's a moral issue as well
a spiritual issue as well it is but i
want to clarify something i want to i
want i want you to explain this to me
you're speaking to the issue of
cohabitating you're not speaking just to
the issue of singleness because the
issue of singleness you can't really
tolerate no no no no
no i'm not i'm not you're exactly okay i
want to clarify that you know
and and you know having babies outside
of wedlock yeah
old-fashioned phrase okay but the
statistical evidence is it's disastrous
for your life yeah
yeah the numbers show it the numbers
show it yeah and so
you know there's something to a shotgun
wedding you know
or like you told christina by friday you
get her pregnant daddy comes up with a
shotgun you're going to marry her
i mean that's old-school hillbilly stuff
right but there's something to that
because what it does is it sets you up
not in the moment
yeah but it sets you up for a pattern of
decisions going forward
that cause your next 10 years you're
twice as likely to be a homeowner
you are 10x less likely to be on welfare
yeah it's pretty that's pretty dramatic
it is
it is and the numbers show it what's
interesting and i don't think we have
the data on this but i'm curious because
you get calls a lot of times too dave
and this may not be as common but you
see a pattern where people are married
but not working as a team they've got
their own bank accounts they've got
their hidden debts they've got all this
stuff
and you're seeing an economic disaster
in their even even though they're
married because they're not working as a
team
you're seeing the house crumble in on
itself exactly because of the behavior
but what's so interesting is when you
have the
the commitment of marriage the structure
of marriage the
uh teamwork element you're forced to
work as a team it's much more conducive
to
those results you're talking about
because you have committed you're
putting things together and you're
working as a team
if you don't it's still going to be a
problem yeah if you're not a team
it's just it for your own daughter
you know you gotta look at her and go if
he gets the warmth of your bed he gets
the 26
car loan yeah yeah i mean yeah
these things go together yeah baby doll
yeah i mean why are you calling in the
dave ramsey so show stressed out
about your 26 interest and he's chasing
emt school i'm not against emt school
but i'm like it feels like he is
moving forward with his goals and you
are trying to clean up
problems in the past we need to
reconcile these two yeah and then and
then make decisions as a team together
as to what's good for the team the
family unit and most of all for this
baby this one
that's right there's such an urgency
because of that and so um
i i just i want you guys out there to
hear
uh this is not holier than thou this is
not talking down to someone
there's some economic and statistical
details and indicators that are
really not arguable uh that you're that
are gonna that you're that you're
swimming upstream against well you can
disagree with the morality you can
disagree with your stance or
religious stance or moral stance and the
numbers still don't change
the results economically exactly there
was no indication i mean i didn't bring
up
church attendance yeah but um you know
by the way
that does in their enter into also a
wealth building thing but
a higher likelihood regular worship
attendance
whether you're christian jewish muslim
regular worship attendance is correlated
with
a higher probability of building wealth
because a character
is being built and you know it's a
pretty simple things when you think
about it
but you cannot leave these things
separate from i'm just going to ask a
math question
doesn't work sorry guys this is how it
is we love you guys we want you to win
this is the dave ramsey show